in Britain it's usually called a weather
bomb scientifically it's the same thing
the UK experienced it most famously in
1987 during the great storm
more recently storm Dennis hit Europe in
February 2020 seven people died as Winds
of up to 91 miles per hour hit parts of
England and Wales
these intense storms can occur anywhere
but North America is particularly prone
to them with some studies suggesting the
region gets 18 bomb Cyclones a year
meteorologist Mike Mogul has first-hand
experience of this extreme weather the
North Pacific is is the most likely
place
um to see these that the North Pacific
has a very very active jet stream
pattern it's linked to the Himalayas and
uh you know the difference between the
land and water and the Western Pacific a
bomb Cyclone is a storm that intensifies
very rapidly they form when warm and
cold air masses collide with the warm
air Rising fast through the atmosphere
this triggers a sudden drop in
atmospheric pressure which draws in
cooler air to fill the Gap as long as
the warm air continues to rise pressure
will continue to drop drawing in more
cold air underneath
in this case the cold air is being drawn
down from the Arctic and as you can see
here that's bringing freezing conditions
usually seen only in Northern Canada
down across much of the United States
today across large parts of the U.S
millions of people face temperatures as
low as minus 45 degrees Celsius it is a
dangerous drop the weather changes so
rapidly so you wind up that you could
have sunny skies and an hour later you
could wind up with three inches of snow
on the ground
um and the storm if it has cold air
associated with it can come in and drop
temperatures dramatically and you wind
up with What's called the flash freeze
so any water that's sitting on roadways
or or power lines
um just freezes almost instantaneously
along with the life-threatening
inclineding blizzards freezing rain and
flooding are all contra contritting to
the Mayhem this Christmas but the worst
could be over the storm is now in
Eastern Canada and it's weakening and it
will probably
um wind down over the next 24 to 36
hours and then move out into the far
Northwest Atlantic west of uh
of Greenland
and dissipate the Met Office says the
storm in North America won't directly
impact the UK's weather but that
temperature changes there will
strengthen a low pressure system here
and that is set to bring the UK's North
wet and windy weather and a chance of
snow it is the Met Office says typical
for this time of year sadio chadri Sky
News